time for lunch in the gym punchy
wildlife orphanage in Northwest Zambia
more and more chimpanzees are gathering
in the trees close to the feeding
station the staff here prepare meals for
the Apes twice a day
innocent Mulenga heads up the chimpanzee
reserve
he's known some of the chimps since he
was a child the food is served at the
station at the edge of the forest the
system is designed to make sure all of
the animals are fed we feed them in such
a big house because we want to separate
the males from the females and the young
ones because the males are dominant and
they always want to eat everything so
this is why we separate them aside from
the feeding times the chimps live just
like their counterparts in the wild the
fence encloses around 150 hectares much
of it undisturbed rainforest the fence
is there to protect the animals from
humans
poachers are the chimps worst enemy the
idea really is for this gypsy to have a
good home this is why we have put all
these big enclosures for them like in
here put 47 of them and we are there to
provide protection for them because in
the world they are hunted heavy but
they're safe as long as they stay inside
the gym funky enclosures back in the
forests they originally inhabited the
animals wouldn't survive long most of
the chimpanzees that you fishing come
from more Congo which is like 18
kilometers from here
but in Congo these lawlessness there
there was there and so this difference
is they are prone to poachers and people
that doing push me trade the chimpanzee
wildlife orphanage was set up in 1983 by
a farming couple a german entrepreneur
later took over financing today his
family continues to ensure that the
people here also profit from the project
for example with a school for the
children of the sanctuaries employees we
put our cassia that work for the chimps
and really there is no school anywhere
near so in 2007 Liberty so that their
children can have a decent education
chief who she is not just about
chimpanzees but also about the humans
and this is why this project is looking
at helping the children get quite
education that costs money which is why
the project recently bought a nearby
farm on its grounds fruit and crops are
harvested to help feed the chimps while
cattle are raised to provide income
tally Takai we also helps take care of
the animals at chim phone she'd she's
Brazilian and has been living and
working here for two years though she
does farm work she's actually here for
the chimps she's grown very fond of the
animals we need to take opportunities
like this of doing an enrichment or
offering something different to be able
to see all of them to have a good eye on
it to check for who is coughing who is
sneezing who is losing weight the
animals aren't forced to interact with
humans if they don't wish to the idea is
to let them live lives as free as
possible from human interference but
some chimps need help and attention
chiffon has a complicated past like the
other chimp in his cage he was unable to
integrate into one of the bands here
talita spends as much time with him as
she can
t-phone is a former pet he was with a
family for very long so he doesn't
really know how to fit in the chimp
family how to behave like a proper chimp
he has the need to be with people and
also to have some kind of interactions
chiffons group is slated to get its own
large outdoor enclosure in the coming
months just like the other chimpanzees
that have found a new home at the chimp
hunchy wildlife orphanage